Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I’m going to
explain a horror drama film called “The B4d S33d.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we see a
nine-year-old girl named Emma Grossman,
watching a cat drowning in a fountain through her
room’s window. She closes the blinds, and goes on
with her morning routine, showing no remorse to
the drowning cat. Emma lives with her widowed
father named David Grossman. She is an excellent
student and a well-mannered kid. However,
she seems to have no human emotions. That day
at breakfast, Emma tells him of her ambition to
win a citizenship award at school. As the
two talk, Emma’s aunt, Angela, comes in.
She informs David of a new babysitter she has
found for Emma. It turns out that Emma’s previous
babysitter suffered an "unfortunate accident".
As they talk, Emma points out the dead cat in
the fountain. David brings the cat out, but Emma
seems void of any emotions about its death.
That day at school, a wasp scares the children
as they study. As the students retreat in fear,
Emma bravely takes a glass and captures the
wasp to let it fly outside the window.
Meanwhile, David interviews a babysitter named
Chloe. He likes her portfolio of work, so he hires
her. Chloe seems to be interested in David.
Back at school, Emma’s classmate, Katie,
is playing when she bumps into Emma who helps her
get up. Their teacher watches the events unfold.
It looks as if Emma is trying to be compassionate
to win the citizenship award. That night,
Emma practises smiling in front of the mirror.
The following day is the award day. David dresses
up Emma and drives her to school. All the
parents and students are seated in the audience,
when the teacher announces that Milo has won the
citizenship award. Emma is beyond disappointed.
When David talks to Emma about Milo’s win,
she says that she was the one who deserved it,
and begins insulting Milo. She apologizes
when David looks at her disapprovingly.
Sometime later, when no one is watching, Emma
takes Milo to show him a cliff nearby.
When Milo suggests returning, Emma walks towards
him, and the screen goes blank. Later, when Milo’s
parents ask her if she has seen him, she lies
and says she hasn’t seen him since the bonfire.
Suddenly, two girls come running from somewhere,
screaming for help. All the parents run to see
Milo has fallen off the cliff and drowned in the
ocean. His father carries his washed-up body,
and tries giving him CPR; but Milo is dead.
The following morning at breakfast,
David asks Emma how she feels, but she completely
ignores the fact her friend died the day before.
Later, the new babysitter, Chloe,
comes to the house. That night,
David isn’t home. Emma finds Chloe in David’s
room stealing some of David’s medicines.
Later as they watch movies, Emma
confronts her about the drugs.
She promises to not tell David if Chloe does what
she wants. Emma then orders her to get her an ice
cream. Chloe calls the little girl a bitch, but
does what she says. The following day is Milo’s
memorial. After the ceremony, everyone is crying
except for Emma. David talks to Milo’s parents,
and finds out that the medal is missing. They
assume that it sank in the ocean. Just then,
Emma begins to cry too. It is as if she is
pretending to be sad in front of Milo’s parents.
When they come back home, David is
worried about Emma's behaviour.
When he folds Emma’s laundry that day, we see
that Milo’s medal is hidden under Emma’s mattress.
David looks through the pictures of the
award day, and finds several pictures of
Emma glaring at Milo. He suspects that his
death has to do something with Emma.
Later that day, Emma’s teacher ,Mrs Ellis, and a
police officer visit David to talk about Milo’s
death. Mrs. Ellis claims that someone had seen
Emma with Milo in the cliff before his death.
Emma listens to their conversation from the door.
She fakes falling on a vase and hurting herself
to stop the adults from talking. Seeing that Emma
is hurt, Mrs. Ellis and the officer leave. While
taking care of Emma’s wound, David asks her if she
was with Milo in the cliff, but Emma denies. When
he reveals that Mrs. Ellis said she was, Emma gets
agitated and yells that Mrs. Ellis hates her.
The following day, Chloe goes to their
side house where David is working.
She asks him if she can smoke there, but David
denies, saying that the place has too many
inflammable liquids. Right after, Chloe takes
Emma to the street to play with her scooter.
While they are at it, the two see Mrs. Ellis’s
car in front of Milo’s home. She is talking to
Milo’s mother. Chloe says that they are building
a case against Emma. She knows that Emma did
something to Milo. However, the little girl acts
like she doesn’t know what Chloe is talking about.
When they come back home, they continue the
conversation. Chloe tells Emma that if they
find out what happened to Milo, they will sit
Emma in an electric chair. This scares Emma,
but she still doesn’t admit to doing anything.
Later that day, Chloe is looking for Emma around
the house, when we notice the wasp nest that
had been in the ceiling of the outhouse is gone.
Then, we see Mrs. Ellis drive away from Milo’s
home. As she drives, a wasp distracts her which
almost causes an accident. She continues to
drive when the camera pans to the back seat.
The wasp’s nest lies there. Emma has put the
nest in the car to try and kill her teacher.
Back at home, Chloe finds Milo’s medal under
Emma’s mattress. She hangs it in a lamp in
David’s dresser so that Emma can be caught. David
is in his bathroom, when Emma comes to his room
and sees the medal. She gets it off the lamp
and hides it behind her, but David notices.
He brings her back to her room, and confronts her
about it. Emma lies and makes up a story about
Milo giving the medal to her as they played.
David goes for a drive to take mind off this,
when he sees a car crashed on the side of
the road. He also calls Angela and asks
her to find Emma a therapist. David begins
to get nightmares about Emma and Milo.
The following day, Emma confronts Chloe about
her putting the Medal there. She is furious.
Just then, David comes downstairs and asks
Emma to come with him. He takes her to Milo’s
home to return the medal back to his mom. She is
confused, but thankful that she brought it back.
She then informs them about Mrs. Ellis‘s death.
She had had a car accident because of the wasps.
David is surprised. Emma begins to cry, claiming
that Mrs. Ellis was her favorite teacher.
However, on their way home, Emma seems to
have forgotten about Mrs. Ellis’s death and
talks about baking cookies with Chloe. David is
unsettled by Emma’s behaviour. Later, as David
is working in the outhouse, he notices that the
wasp’s nest is gone. He suspects his daughter for
Mrs. Ellis’s death. The following day is Emma’s
first appointment with her therapist, Dr. March.
She and Emma have a long chat. After the session,
the doctor tells David that Emma is like any other
normal child; Emma even fooled a psychiatrist!
When the two come back home, David comes across
Chloe sunbathing in her sports bra. He asks her
to go to Emma. As Chloe and Emma talk, she tells
the little girl that David was looking at her
seductively earlier. She also adds that she can
be her step mother. Furious, Emma screams at her
to stay away from her dad. That night, Emma asks
David if he likes Chloe. David is confused. She
also reveals about Chloe wanting to be her step
mother. However, David is late for a date, so he
leaves without giving her much of an explanation.
Some time later, Chloe hears a noise as she
is watching TV. She goes looking for Emma,
but cannot find her anywhere. She looks at the out
house through the window and sees a shadow there.
She goes out to look for her.
When she gets into the outhouse,
the door closes. She tries to open it but it seems
to be locked from outside. Just then a fire starts
spreading on the floor. Chloe sees Emma watch her
through the window. She tries to hit her but the
fire indulges her, killing her eventually. David
comes home to the firefighters and paramedics in
his house; they tell him about Chloe’s death.
Emma has been taken to an official's home;
he finally gets to Emma and hugs her.
That night, David comes to Emma’s room.
He sits down in front of her and lovingly asks
her if she hurt Milo. He assures her that he
will do anything he can to help her, but she
has to tell him the truth. Emma finally admits
that she pushed Milo off the cliff. She makes an
excuse by saying that he was going to report her
for taking his medal.She then casually says that
she won’t do it again. David is horrified.
He then asks her about Mrs Levia, Emma’s previous
babysitter. She reveals that she pushed her down
the stairs because Mrs. Levia grabbed her hand.
She then claims that Levia should have been more
careful. Emma gets progressively aggressive as
she talks. When asked about what she did to Chloe,
she yells at David and blames Chloe for trying
to be her stepmother. David is anxious; he cannot
believe that his little daughter can commit such
a horrible crime. The following morning, the town
Sheriff calls David and says he wants to meet
Emma. However, David makes an excuse about her
being sick. He then takes her to their lake house
far away. Their housekeeper welcomes them.
Later that day, the Sheriff calls David again to
inform him that the fire was set deliberately by
someone, but they don’t know who. Seeing that
his daughter might get caught, he is anxious.
David has a gun with him at the house. He looks
at it now and then thinking if he can put it
to use to solve the situation. The following
day, as David is asleep, Emma comes into his
room and kisses him. She closes all the windows
and turns all the gas stoves on in an attempt
to kill her father. Emma then goes by the lake
and stays there. Just then, David wakes up and
smells the gas filling up the house. He quickly
opens the windows, and turns the stoves off.
He sees Emma outside at the lake, and
realizes that she has tried to kill him.
He walks up to her and asks her why she did that.
Emma replies that if something happened to him,
she gets to go live with her aunt, Angela,
who actually likes her. David holds her hand
and calmly takes her into the house. Then, we
see David crush his medicines. Later, he brings
Emma a cup of hot chocolate. The two drink the hot
chocolate together and David tucks her to sleep.
When he comes back to his room, he calls Angela
and tells her everything about Emma’s wrongdoings
but she doesn’t believe him. He apologizes to
Angela and vaguely tells her that he has no other
options. It turns out that David had added drugs
in Emma’s hot chocolate in order to overdose her,
so that she doesn’t kill more people.
But he doesnt tell Angela this.
That night when he is asleep, Emma enters
his room. She holds a gun in his hand and
points it at himself. She fires, but misses,
sending the bullet to the pillow beside David.
The noise wakes him up and he asks her how is she
still alive. Emma replies that she had switched
her hot chocolate with David’s. Seeing that she
was about to kill him, David leaps to snatch the
gun from her hand. Emma quickly takes his phone
and calls 911. She then runs away to the bathroom
as David follows her with the intention to
kill her. Emma tells the 911 operator that
her father is trying to kill her.
David breaks open the bathroom door
and points his gun at Emma. Just then, the
housekeeper appears behind him with his rifle.
When David is about to kill Emma, he shoots him
instead. Emma watches as her father falls down
to the ground and dies. The police arrive too.
Cut to the following morning, Aunt Angela arrives
at the scene. She tells Emma that her
dad was probably sick. The movie ends as
we see Emma hug Angela and smirk, with
a cold predatory look on her face.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.